all right let's give a warm Nevada
welcome Republican Senate candidate Adam
laxal joins us
there's a bottle of water if you're
thirsty great to see you how are you
we're great we're ready to charge the
hill here
um it's interesting to watch you you are
in the lead now in this race it's a two
right yeah
you have a two-point race this would be
a needed pickup if there's any hope for
Republicans to take back control of the
Senate tell us why you're competent
these polls are going to hold up and
you'll probably do better
look the bottom line is
um all your National viewers know what's
going on in the country we have high
inflation we have all these things but
in Nevada it's far worse we have 16
inflation here you could pay over six
dollars a gallon for gas so the rest of
the country is 8.5 you have twice the
level of inflation twice the level tied
for the highest in the country and so
and and again by the way Terry feder is
here who has the number one show on on
the strip
that means people that means for your
locals are going to your
wow
so you know this economy that Senator
masto has voted for all of these Biden
bills has made our state absolutely
unaffordable it is unsustainable and it
cuts across work in class it cuts across
Hispanic voters people are absolutely
fed up and then you add of course the
rise in crime and our border issues I'm
sure we can get to it is a perfect
cocktail of everything going wrong in
Las Vegas and that's why we're going to
flip the seat you know it what's
Happening Here
thank you
what's happening in Nevada is
interesting because it's happening all
across the country now I know everyone
wants to blame Joe Biden and by the way
he deserves his I don't think he knows
that today is Tuesday but that's a
different different story but it's every
Democrat now they've all bought into
this radicalism which is okay they want
higher taxes they want the new green
deal which is a shift from capitalism to
socialism right they don't want us to
produce energy domestically which is
insane they're begging our enemies for
the lifeblood of our economy they want
open borders they have you know they're
all supporting defund dismantle and no
bail laws and they don't want to educate
our kids with Reading Writing and math
they'd rather talk about gender identity
and you know sex education and I think
parents would prefer we go back to math
reading Science and History
and you know
what I think is worse about all this is
that someone like Senator masto she
won't run on her record you know so all
these Democrats they support these
policies that you listed but then they
put commercials on for Nevada voters and
they put something else in front of the
public and they lie about their records
so if you believe in this stuff and you
vote for this stuff go sell it to the
American public but they're not willing
to stand behind these policies and a lot
of these policies we never voted on no
one here voted on the green New Deal we
did not vote for okay if you go after
American Energy Independence it's going
to give you six dollar gas if we got to
vote on that this state you better
believe Democrats would have lost last
election but they sneak it all in yeah
you know it's so important uh he's been
very gracious he flew across country to
be with us tonight uh let's give a warm
Nevada welcome to uh South Carolina
Senator Tim Scott Senator Scott come on
in
thank you
thank you my friend how are you
everybody
hello Nevada
wow
I like this it's good to be with you by
the way Terry fader you may have
competition on the strip I don't know
what you know is that Sean Hannity
doesn't have competition on any show
[Music]
you're great you know I've you've been
gracious enough to come to these Town
Halls because it's important yes and one
thing that you've been saying and
Lindsay's been saying and every other
Republican that if if Adam laxalt does
not win and I believe you will win that
will that that will cancel out the vote
of of people like you and Lindsay and
other Senators that have a different
vision for the country listen my life
story isn't possible in any other
country on earth I was born I mean this
is the country I was born and raised in
a single parent household mired in
poverty it's the American system of free
markets in capitalism it was a mentor a
republican Conservative Christian who
taught me that all things were possible
in America if we lose that
nothing good happens for the world
electing Adam laxalt is one of the ways
that we protect create a firewall in the
United States Senate
elect Adam laxalt some people little
boys little girls like me get to grow up
and be the man that God wants us to be
think about it this way
I get so excited about our country I
love this country
America is always the solution we are
never the problem always a solution
think about this
when we were in charge from 2016 to 2020
president Trump and a republican
controlled Congress created seven
million jobs two-thirds going to women
African-Americans and Hispanics the most
inclusive economy in the history of
America brought to you by the Republican
party right
it was the Republican party that brought
HBCU funding to the highest level in the
history of the country it was the
Republican historically black colleges
it was the Republican party that brought
unemployment rates to the lowest level
for Hispanics under five percent African
Americans under six percent agents under
three percent the overall population
three and a half percent it's the Biden
Administration that has provided every
single American with a pay cut because
of inflation inflation is a tax on
hard-working Americans like the single
mom that raised me we can't afford
14 more days
14 more days of this Administration but
if we elect him in 14 days
two years later we'll get rid of
President Biden too
[Applause]
Revival in America you know let me go
back to it
Adam laxalt so to me being a
conservative I can say it in less than a
minute we believe in Liberty Freedom
capitalism uh our constitution we
believe in less government less
bureaucracy we believe in Law and Order
and Safety and Security in every town
every city you can't pursue happiness
without it we believe in education and
the parents should have a say in their
kids education Reading Writing Math
Science History right the basics we
believe in Secure borders we believe in
peace through strength we believe in
free and fair trade we believe in
constitutionalists on the bench we also
believe as a country we should be energy
independent not sucking up to Saudi
Arabia right
those are all issues you addressed on
the campaign Trail and where you stand
you will be a great partner with Senator
Tim Scott and Mike Lee who will join us
in a little bit that tell us how you
became the conservative you are
let me just say that it'll take the
Hispanic vote here in Las Vegas and
everything that you just mentioned is
under assault right now and and people
moved to Las Vegas because they believed
the American dream this is still an
oasis here you can come out west you can
work hard and you can actually move into
the middle class and grow raise and grow
family what's happening to the Hispanic
community in Las Vegas is why you're
seeing this massive shift they're
killing our schools they shut them down
during covet we have rise in crime we
have open borders which of course
senator masto says there's no such thing
as an open border and this is allowed
fentanyl overdoses human trafficking
Spikes all these things are combining
with the high gas prices the inflation
the job market the American dream is
disappearing in Las Vegas that's why
you're seeing people ready to raise up
and tell people like senator masto they
don't represent them anymore you know
what the strange thing is is as I was
following your race from the earliest
days that I had to First on my radio
show and I'm like who's senator masto
who was that and the reason we know so
little about her is she is a rubber
stamp Chuck Schumer Joe Biden voter
absolutely she never puts a ripple in
the water just is it a reliable liberal
Democratic Socialist vote hey look as
everybody here knows she's been running
commercials that she's an independent
she's never she's she acts like she's
never even heard of Joe Biden I remind
people that she was on the VP short list
her husband and Hunter Biden are close
buddies they go way back and the fact of
the matter is she's hiding from Joe
Biden because she's voted with him 100
time with his economic agenda she
supported the open borders policies and
law enforcement Las Vegas Metro's here
they left her and they supported me
because they know I'll stay in the law
enforcement let me ask you both we have
about a minute before we have to go to
break there is a phenomenon it's
happening around the country showing up
in every poll Hispanic America
African-Americans they are moving in big
numbers to the Republican side what's
happening Senator well simple we are a
party we are the great opportunity party
our doors are open for everybody the
difference is we're walking out of our
doors and into the neighborhoods we're
having a common sense conversation with
people at their kitchen table about
their priorities not ours America
Americans love this country and every
single time we give them a chance to
vote for us because we they know we're
on their side Sean they know we're on
their side whether it's the economy
whether it's fighting crime the
Democrats say blame the police we say
let's respect the police let's stand for
the police let's love the police just
appreciate the police he has the backing
of law enforcement because we stand for
the police they want to defund the
police we say refund the police
African-Americans 80 plus want the same
level of policing in their neighborhoods
or more
the mass media has sold minorities a lie
you're standing up for all of us God
bless you Senator the last 30 seconds
is this change real it's in almost every
poll I read look I think it's going to
be lasting as long as we are the party
of the American dream opportunity Law
and Order safety secure borders school
choice all these things are going to
turn Hispanic Community permanently to
our Direction hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else